[Applause]
rousey's going to be fine but perhaps
worse somebody get in there and help the
ramp yeah ronda rousey won't be seeing
the ring anytime soon after the wwe
suspends her indefinitely for attacking
a summerslam official let's break it
down my background in dealing in high
pressure situations really helps a lot
it all went down during the wrestlers
smackdown women's title match versus liv
morgan rhonda wisely rolling out but the
damage could be done at one point during
the match referee dan engler missed liv
tapping out to the armbar so he
continued counting the pinfall and in
the end liv ultimately won the title
yeah and that's when rhonda unleashed
her wrath on the ref
oh i'll announce attacking the referee
rousey's going to be fine but perhaps
worse somebody get in there and help the
wrap ronda rousey is on a rampage at
summerslam
ronda rousey is snapped and ronda's
behavior didn't fly with the wwe the
organization released a statement
stating quote following her attack on
referee dan angler at summerslam ronda
rousey has been fined in undisclosed
amount and will be suspended that means
she will not appear on this week's
friday night smackdown and rhonda she
isn't going into her suspension quietly
when i'm fighting i like to show that
ambition in a woman is something that
should be celebrated two days after the
event the 35 year old athlete shared
pics from her match with liv writing in
caption
hey wwe if you guys could stop screwing
me to put over your golden girls at
every major pay-per-view that'd be great
okay so ronda's probably not letting
this situation set her back before her
wwe days while she was full-time in her
ufc career she revealed to e.t why she
works so hard i'm very fearful of
failure which is why i work so much
harder than any of these other girls and
why i
haven't really
leaned back to enjoy the lifestyle of a
champion because i always feel like this
is also fleeting and fragile and i
really have to work hard to protect it
every single day and i i guess i don't
have the
the the confidence to just sit back and
enjoy it i'm constantly working to keep
it
[Music]
you